في يوليو من عام 2000، استقبل الرئيس بيل كلينتون رئيس
الوزراء الإسرائيلي إيهود
باراك والزعيم الفلسطيني ياسر
عرفات في منتجعه الرئاسي في
كامب ديفيد، وكان هدفهم إنهاء
الصراع المستمر منذ عقود مرة واحدة وإلى الأبد
بعد أسبوعين بدا أنهم
قريبون بشكل مثير من التوصل إلى اتفاق تاريخي
حتى عام 2000.  انسحب الفلسطينيون وانهارت
المحادثات في وقت لاحق من ذلك العام، واندلع
العنف في جميع أنحاء المنطقة
لبدء الانتفاضة الفلسطينية المعروفة باسم
الأب الثاني في ذلك الوقت،
وقد تراجعت منذ فترة طويلة آفاق السلام الدائم
معي أحد اللاعبين الرئيسيين في تلك
القمة أهود باراك أه  رئيس الوزراء
باراك هو حلم
حل الدولتين أه كما تعلم مجرد
خيال كامل في هذه المرحلة أعني أنني أفكر
في الخريطة التي أه كلينتون اقترحتها
في النهاية جميع
معايير كلينتون أه التي أعرف أنها تأتي من
دينيس روس  ولم يتم قبولها من قبل
أي من الجانبين ولكن كما تعلم فإن ذلك يعطيك
إحساسًا بوجود إمكانية لنوع
من الحل العقلاني هنا الذي
حصل عليه الفلسطينيون في تلك الخريطة التي
لم يتم قبولها ولكنها كانت قريبة مما
تم عرضه 93% 94% من  ما كان لديهم
هو كل هذا الموت مع هذه الموجة من
المستوطنات التي حدثت في
العشرين عامًا الماضية، وأنتم فلسطينيون، كما تعلمون،
السلطة الفلسطينية لا تتمتع
بمصداقية كبيرة
على أي حال، يبدو أن هذا ليس الوقت المناسب
لمناقشة الأمر لأننا الآن في حالة حرب
و  أولا وقبل كل شيء، نحن نركز على
القضاء على القدرات العسكرية
لحماس وإخراجها من الصورة
في قطاع غزة ولكن إذا
سألتني على المدى الطويل هناك
قول روماني قديم اه إذا كنت لا تعرف أي
ميناء  تريد الوصول، لا توجد ريح ستأخذك إلى
هناك وأولئك الذين يبحرون يعرفون أنه
إذا كانت لديك رياح
معاكسة، فيجب عليك أن تسير بشكل متعرج من أجل الوصول إلى هذا
الهدف.
المستقبل الذي
تحتاجه إسرائيل ليس بسبب العدالة
للفلسطينيين، بل بسبب أمننا
وهويتنا المستقبلية، ولكن
هناك جدل كبير في إسرائيل حول
الجانب الآخر من الخريطة السياسية بقيادة نيتان
وهذين
الرجلين العنصريين المسيحانيين اللذين تعاونا معاً  مع أن
لديهم دولة مختلفة يريدون
دولة واحدة يريدون عرقلة الأمر برمته
بطريقة ما في أساس
هذا الصراع في الأسبوعين الماضيين،
يمكن تلخيص استراتيجيتهم أو التي اتخذها نيتان في السنوات الخمس الماضية
في  الجملة حماس هي أحد الأصول
والقضية الفلسطينية هي مسؤولية
وليس العكس، لماذا
هذا لأنه إذا كانت حماس لا تزال على قيد الحياة
ولا يمكن لأحد أن يجادلنا في
بدء التفاوض مع الفلسطينيين
لأننا نستطيع بسهولة أن
تقول الحكومة ذلك بسهولة  أبو معن لا يسيطر
حتى على نصف شعبه ومع
كاما لن يطلب منا أحد
التفاوض مع منظمة إرهابية، لذا
فهي في الأساس طريقة غير مباشرة لمنع
إمكانية قيام دولتين، لذا
ليس هذا هو الوقت المناسب للتعامل معها لأنه
علينا أن نتحد وقبل كل شيء أن نهزم
كاماس على الأرض في وقت لاحق، سيأتي
يوم نغادر فيه ك ديفيد، أقول
سواء استغرق الأمر 5 15، فهو بالفعل أكثر
من 20 أو 50 عامًا في النهاية، سيأتي
الوقت للقيام بذلك  سيتم
التوصل إلى اتفاق في مرحلة معينة، وسوف تحتاج إلى
عدسة مكبرة لمعرفة الفرق
بين ما كان مطروحًا على الطاولة وما
سيتم إبرامه، وبعد سنوات قليلة من إبرام
الصفقة، لن يستطيع أحد أن
يشرح لماذا استغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً بحق الجحيم.
وكان يجب دفن الكثير من الناس من
الطرفين أه أخيرا وبسرعة يا رئيس
الوزراء باراك قلت أن بنيامين
نتنياهو هو المسؤول عن أكبر
فشل في تاريخ إسرائيل هل يستطيع
البقاء كرئيس للوزراء بعد هذا
الفشل تعرف إذا سألت الناس
سيفعلون  أخبرك لا، أنت تعلم أنه حصل على
ثقة التفويض من أجل
تشكيل الحكومة منذ حوالي 10 أشهر
أو أكثر قليلاً، لقد
تبخرت الثقة خلال 7 أكتوبر
تمامًا، لا أحد يثق خاصة مع
هذين الاثنين في ميشيغان في حكومته
أه وأه إذا نظرت إلى استطلاعات الرأي
التي مرت في الأسبوع الماضي
ستجد أن 70% من الجمهور الإسرائيلي
يريد استقالة نتنياهو ونصفهم
يريد أن يستقيل فوراً والآخر
يقول في نهاية الحرب ولكن في رأيهم
بالهم عندهم حرب إسرائيل حرب ستة أيام
كانت أسبوع أه 73 حرب حرب ضخمة ثلاثة
أسابيع أطول صراع في
الجيل الأخير قبل 5 سنوات كان أقل من
شهرين لذلك يقولون شهرين دعونا نعض
شفاهنا ونقاتل ونضعها
الرف ولكن عندما تبدأ في الغناء من
حيث عالم طويل، فقد
يستغرق الأمر كما ذكر عدة أشهر
وربما بضع سنوات أو أكثر من عام،
فهذا يمهد الأمر بطريقة مختلفة،
لا أعتقد أن الجمهور يثق في
نتنياهو  لقيادة هذه الحرب،
يسعد الجميع أن بندقية وآيسن أو
اثنين من زعماء المعارضة الذين صادف أن يكون كلاهما
رئيسًا لأركان القوات المسلحة
وأحدهما حتى وزير
الدفاع، مما يجعل الناس يشعرون
بمزيد من الأمان من أن القرار غير المسؤول
لن يحدث.  لا يتم ذلك ولكن بعد أن قلت أن
الناس يتوقعون المساءلة،
يؤسفني نوعًا ما أن أخبرك أنه
لا توجد كلمة عبرية للمساءلة فكر
في سبب ذلك ولكن حان الوقت
للمطالبة بالمساءلة وأعتقد أن
آه كما تعلم الجميع يقول لك أوه هو
لم ينته الأمر بعد، نتنياهو يركز على
البقاء وعلى إطلاق سراح نفسه،
وما نسميه آلة السموم التي
تلوم الآخرين على المسؤولية
تعمل على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع خلف الكواليس، هناك
إحاطة ضد الأسلحة ضد
ضد قيادة الجيش ضد
الأذكياء  الجميع مسؤول
باستثناء الرجل في القمة،
فالهدف يجب أن يكون القضاء على أي
قدرة عسكرية لكاما وقدرته على السيطرة على
المجموعة،
ولا ننوي محو أيديولوجية أو
رغبات وأحلام العديد من أعضاء
كاماس و  إنه في جميع أنحاء
عالم الواقع المعزز، هناك جزء من جماعة الإخوان المسلمين الأوسع
وتركيا وبعض
الأشخاص في
قطر، لا يمكننا محو حماس
ككيان ولكن باعتبارنا
مشغلًا عسكريًا في غزة
وكحاكم لغزة، يمكننا القيام بذلك
بالطبع لا يمكن إكمالها من
الجو ستحتاج إلى هذه
العملية البرية الضخمة بآلاف
وربما عشرات الآلاف من القوات على
الأرض إدارة بايدن أه
من أفضل ما يمكننا قوله تحذير
إسرائيل من الحرص على عدم التورط بشكل
أكبر من أه  كما تعلم، نوع من
الدمار اه اه غزة تمامًا مرة أخرى، لقد
فعلت هذا هل هذا ممكن اه كما
تعلم أم أن فكرة الذهاب إلى هناك
بأعداد كبيرة تذهب إلى الباب
أيضًا كما تعلم من نفق إلى نفق من مبنى
إلى
مبنى  انظر أه أود أن أقول إنني
لم أقل مطلقًا كلمة لا مفر منها في
الشؤون العسكرية
ولكن أه أود أن أقول أن أكثر من 90% سنرى
في الأيام القادمة
غزوًا كبيرًا لقطاع غزة سيستغرق الأمر
حتى اتخاذ القرار  الجزء الشمالي من
قطاع غزة سيستغرق بعض الوقت
ربما أسبوعين أو أيا كان ثلاثة
أسابيع يعتمد على وتيرة الأمر كله واحد
ولكن تنظيفه من أه المادية
والموارد البشرية للكامس
قد يستغرق عدة أسابيع أو أو عدة
أشهر  قبل اكتمالها ونحن
ندرك أننا لا ننوي البقاء هناك
إلى الأبد، يجب أن تواجه العملية برمتها
أربعة قيود مختلفة، الأول هو
الرهائن والآخر هو خطر
انتشاره إلى صراع أوسع بكثير
مع هيه في لبنان وربما آخرين
الثالث  الأول هو كيفية إدارة هذا الحوار
مع القانون الدولي، فنحن
ملتزمون بالقانون الدولي وندرك
تمامًا أن
دعمنا وشرعيتنا العالمية سوف تتآكل لفترة طويلة
عندما تتزايد أعداد الأشخاص
المواطنين الذين يتعرضون للضرب هناك.
على الرغم من حقيقة أن سبب
وجودهم هناك هو حقيقة
أن حماس تجبرهم على أن يصبحوا نوعًا
من الدروع البشرية، إلا أننا ندرك هذه
القيود والسؤال الأخير هو
السؤال لمن يمكننا تمرير Tor
لأننا لا ننوي
ذلك  البقاء هناك لسنوات
قادمة